- Oh (beep).
(laughter)
Oh (beep).
(western music)
(whip crack)
Wait I need a second.
(laughter) Oh my God
I don't wanna do this.
- I mean it looks totally doable.
- Looks and smells delicious,
looks like a Dorito.
- [Cameraman] Three, two, one.
- Yolo.
(crunching)
It's spicy, it tastes just like a Dorito.
- Honestly it's spicy,
but it's not that bad.
- Not the hottest thing that
I've ever had I don't think.
- I think I'm tearing up.
- I am tearing up, oh my God.
- OK wait. (coughs)
- My God.
- My tongue is numb. (coughs)
I'm good are you OK?
- I'm OK, it's starting to hurt now.
- Oh man, I don't, my ears.
- There's like a pain
cemented in all of my mouth.
- OK never mind, taking
that back. (coughs)
- I am tearing up literally right now.
- [Cameraman] Don't touch your eye.
- That is right, I touched my eye
when I was not supposed to.
- I'm not feeling really all that great.
- [Cameraman] Where's the pain?
- Everywhere.
- Oh my God.
- You're crying.
- I have no idea why I signed up for this.
(coughing)
- It's an indescribable pain.
Like there's gasoline on fire in my mouth.
- It feels like someone's
stabbing me inside of my mouth.
It's like getting a bunch
of paper cuts on your gums.
Why would anyone even?
- Yeah maybe it is bad.
- I can't feel my lips right now, but.
(laughter)
- Well you start questioning everything.
- It hurts so much that my tongue
doesn't work the way it's supposed to.
- [Cameraman] So scale of one to 10,
how would you rank this?
- Thousand.
- This is definitely the
spiciest thing I've ever had.
But it's not an enjoyable
spicy thing I would ever want.
It's coming back.
- That's the cruelest thing about it.
You think it's over and then it just.
Oh no, want the garbage can?
- I'm not glad at all.
- I hate my life.
(coughing)
- We signed up for this.
- We did.
- We just see an email and go,
"Yeah that sounds like a good idea".
- Yeah. (laughter)